über dieses tragische flugzeugunglück in
indonesien spreche ich jetzt mit michael
quante unserem luftfahrtexperten hallo
michael ja was ist das besondere was ist
das rätselhafte jetzt an diesem
abstürzen
dieser absturz ist muss unheimlich
schnell gegangen sein die piloten haben
anscheinend keine möglichkeit mehr
gehabt einen notruf abzusetzen sie
müssen so sehr mit der notsituation
beschäftigt gewesen sein dass sie sich
nicht mehr melden konnten und es muss
sehr sehr schnell gegangen sein und die
daten die man von freitag 24 bislang
sehen konnte zeigen ja auch dass diese
maschine sehr sehr schnell sehr sehr
steil mit am ende fast 600 kilometer pro
stunde aufs meer aufgeschlagen ist so
dass da auch die hoffnung auf
überlebende nie vorhanden war grauenhaft
wenn man sich das vorstellt wenn man an
die menschen denkt die da drin saßen
immer wieder passiert es dass flugzeuge
relativ schnell nach dem staat abstürzen
ist das nur ein eindruck oder gibt es
dafür einen besonderen grund
sowohl als auch also aufgrund der
eindrücke der letzten abstürzte den
letzten zwei drei jahren kann man denken
das passiert meistens am start
über alles gesehen das kann man sagen
dass 50 prozent der flugzeugunglücke im
landeanflug passieren und 24 prozent
beim start oder während der startphase
der staat ist eine kritische phase weil
das flugzeug ist immer noch am boden
oder in bodennähe
es wird nahe der minimal geschwindigkeit
geflogen und wenn dann ein zwischenfall
passiert zum beispiel ein triebwerk
ausfall während des starts dann haben
die piloten nur sekundenbruchteile um
noch reagieren die maschine zu stoppen
oder noch mit einem triebwerk zu starten
umzukehren und sicher wieder zu landen
deshalb ist die startphase sehr kritisch
die ursachenforschung hier in diesem
fall dauert ja noch an was ist aber die
meiste unglücksursache wenn es beim
start seinen absturz kommt das ist der
so genannte strömungsabriss bedeutet die
luft geht ja über die tragfläche hinweg
am hinteren ende r stehen unter druck
die maschine wird hochgezogen durch
diesen unter druck das funktioniert aber
nur wenn die tragfläche einen gewissen
anstellwinkel heißt das hat dann
funktioniert das dieser anstellwinkel zu
hoch und die geschwindigkeit zu niedrig
dann kommt es an der tragfläche zu einem
strömungsabriss sind erst verwirbelungen
wer die den piloten richtig angezeigt
werden wird durch sensoren an der
maschine kann
reagieren die nase nach unten drücken
und das ganze stabilisieren wird die zb
durch einen technischen defekt das nicht
angezeigt und er reagiert nicht darauf
dann kann das immer schlimmer werden
dann steigt dieser anstellwinkel auf 18
bis 20 grad
dann kommt zum strömungsabriss und die
maschine fällt nach vorne und fällt dann
wie ein stein zu boden
der strömungsabriss kann auch in einer
kurve passieren wenn eine kurve geflogen
wird gleichzeitig zu steil der
anstellwinkel geschwindigkeit zu niedrig
dann kann die maschine über eine
tragfläche abspielen und feldern wie ein
stein zu boden und aus einer höhe wie
jetzt bei diesem flug von ungefähr 3 300
tausend metern hat auch ein erfahrener
pilot fast keine chance mehr die
maschine da noch abzufangen
aber dafür musste verstehe ich dich
richtig ein technischer fehler also es
muss ihm nicht angezeigt worden sein an
ein pilotenfehler sein es kann aber auch
ein technischer fehler sein gutes
beispiel dafür 1996 der absturz der
bürgen air maschine mit 196 deutschen
urlaubern an bord da ist genau das
geschehen die sensoren haben den piloten
falsche geschwindigkeiten angezeigt die
piloten am darum falsch reagiert es kann
zum strömungsabriss und diese maschine
ist damals dann vor puerto plata in der
dominikanischen republik mit 196
deutschen urlaubern ins meer gestürzt
was vermisst du michael weiss ist hier
in indonesien passiert ich tue mich
schwer mit spekulationen aber ich würde
es wenn man die daten hierzu sieht ist
ein strömungsabriss für mich in diesem
fall die wahrscheinlich die größte
wahrscheinlichkeit aber sicher werde es
erst wissen wenn jetzt die
flugdatenschreiber und noch viel
wichtiger der voice recorder geborgen
wurde
weil dann kann man hören darüber haben
die piloten sich in den letzten sekunden
minuten vor dem absturz und erhalten gab
es ein technisches problem warum konnten
sie nicht reagieren das werden wir erst
ein paar tagen hoffentlich wissen wenn
die datenschreiber geborgen worden und
ausgewertet worden
michael quandt vielen herzlichen dank
für diese interessante analyse für
deinen besuch im studio
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren